finally our next guest is a recent
college grad from a small town in
tennessee who always dreamt of living in
new york city and this spring she
finally got her big dream only to find
out that it was really tiny real tiny
we're talking 72 square feet tiny wow
and she took that micro apartment and
transformed it into a cozy and colorful
home that immediately went viral on tick
tock i am so obsessed with her please
welcome the hendrix
[Applause]
okay so when you first came to new york
city your dream started right then and
there why why was it new york that you
wanted to live here
i came here for the first time with my
parents when i was four years old and we
did the classic new york trip pizza
bagels broadway oh there's that
beautiful picture of me oh
that exact moment on the subway i turned
to my parents and said look i know i'm
for now
but i am going to move to new york city
there's no way you can stop me um i'm
gonna be there and i've been saving
since that time and now i'm here
now you're here you're living in 72
square feet though i got to ask you you
you don't have one clause you don't have
two closet you have zero closets now i
haven't been in the closet for a long
time but i know that they are important
how do you approach
that issue storage in such a small space
first i cried and then after i realized
that i did have to actually tackle the
issue of not having a closet i decided i
kind of wanted to display the things
that would normally be in my closet like
my clothes which are my prized
possession so instead of keeping it all
hidden away it's on display and anytime
anyone comes over they always look at my
clothes which i really love i would love
you to give us your top three take home
tips for anyone working with a small
space via definitely well my first tip
is to use your vertical real estate to
the best of your abilities and for me
that was hanging all of my purses on the
wall and in doing that i was able to
display my beautiful purses and it keeps
the clutter away from the floor which is
a huge part of living in a small space
second tip floating shelves you cannot
go wrong it keeps that clutter off the
floor for me it was displaying my
beautiful shoes
which i also didn't have room for on the
ground and it ended up working out so
perfectly for me i love it your stuff
becomes your art yeah absolutely and you
can see it awesome
number three
yeah third tip would be to use
decorative bins which is a really
specific tip but for me because i don't
have a lot of drawers no closet i needed
something pretty to be able to put my
items into you can find these at your
local hardware store you can diy them i
love using the vertical space i think
that's a real takeaway we think a wall
is a wall and we don't see it as much
more than that maybe you hang some art
on it you're literally giving it storage
i love that function yeah vertical real
estate writing it down yes so much thank
you so much i really appreciate it thea
hendrix thank you so much for coming on
our show today we love you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]